all right georgia yeah
georgia uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally i was born in akron
ohio
uh raised in florida until like
91. i came out here in 89 but
went back and i've been here ever since
what uh
what was your childhood like what was
your childhood like oh
um i was a stupid one
and a pretty stupid one and
pretty much most of my cousins molested
me
uh because i was pretty and um
i ran away from home at 13
and i'm 57 i'll be 67 on father's day
um you ran away at 13 yeah
i i've been on my own i've been married
four times four dawns
all dawn my mom used to say what's with
it with you and john
but um i um
took something from the columbia cartel
years ago and i didn't mean to
i got scared in miami florida and i
got my parents killed and i
haven't been home since
i changed my name to tara
my mother was dying and she kept saying
they're going to kill me they're going
to kill me she was
she was on an oxygen machine and they
went in there and suffocated her
um that was like 20 years later
when you're in the columbia cartel or
whatever
i didn't know i was young you know
and i knew i was with some big time
mafia people
and i just thought it was cool they said
no once you're in you're in
you can't there's no getting out and i
got scared so i took the rent the car
and left and when i took the rental car
and left
it had two kilos of cocaine in it and
130 000 in cash my friend said whether
you take it back
or not they're going to kill you anyway
i said god yeah so i left some money to
my parents
and they were running a run down
downtown saint petersburg they had uh
they were managers of this
would you call it trailer trash park and
uh
one of their neighbors took me to maine
she robbed me of all of it
and kicked me out now i called my
parents
i said i need to come home they said no
no you can't come home
these people called us and told us next
time we see your daughter's gonna be in
a pine box
and there are my father's friends from
coming and he was a biker
in the outlaws in florida and he was a
bartender
so they knew my father and they didn't
want to have to hurt
anyone in my family they wanted me and
i was in maine i was stuck in maine and
then
some kind of ways it's i went through a
lot of [ __ ] to get back
to i never went back to florida what did
they do to your parents
um suffocating them
both your parents yeah um
my father died of lung cancer at 58 but
they went in this room and turned the
socks in and off
my mother was in a nursing home and they
did the same thing to her to kept saying
they're going to kill me they're going
to kill me and that morning my brother
said mom was saying weird [ __ ]
and she was going who mom those guys
those men those men those men
and that like four in the morning they
called my brother
and said your mother had passed someone
turned off for oxygen machine
and i know that was them then
they i married a millionaire
i was working the street i married a
millionaire
he was a trick and he was telling me
that he burned his wife up
two years ago probably i mean two weeks
prior
to being on the hospital getting a hoe
and i said to him your wife just got
burned up in a fire
and you're playing for [ __ ] excuse my
language
why would you do that so i
went on a mission i married a man in las
vegas in a drive-up window
millionaire in anaheim he owned a 4 000
square foot building
and a laminate and copper foil company
and his partner was head of gynecology
from ucla
i was pregnant i got raped and i
had a great baby and
i who i got raped
by who i don't know you don't know some
guy that picked me up
oh i see what are your clients it was
raining and he asked me was that cold
and then
anyway i've been raped like 40 times in
my life
i got scars let me show you
let me show you my legs
i got scars and every part of my body
look at this i went shot stabbed
raped beat bed bugs
something bit me i went to doctors
yesterday
and uh they covered it with this stuff
and sav
and it came off this morning and i don't
have any more i have to buy some more
um i've had three babies
i got paralyzed when i was 16. i got ran
over by my first love my boyfriend
uh he backed over me by accident in
florida
and i was paralyzed from the waist down
they said never had children
well i had three the first one got taken
he was five he got taken from me from
santa ana in santa ana his father called
santa ana police department told him i
was defeated
from florida i was in trouble before he
was ever born
and i was on probation in florida so
they uh
came a deep santana with guns
to my head and i had my son in my arms
and they were going give me the kid and
i'm going please man please
please i mean you guys are still you're
scaring him and screaming mommy
you know what i mean and i had to let
him go
i had to let him go and i haven't seen
him since 31.
so that wasn't my great baby that was my
son's father he was from new york he was
born in stanton and new york
my son alex um
i have a really long story so i'm trying
to break things down just little by
little
um so i've had three children they said
i never have a niece and never walk
i can walk dance jump and if cops behind
me i can run like a [ __ ]
um i've been in prison
seven terms and a discharge for all
seven seven oh seven
and never been back seven is my favorite
number
so my daughter's half hawaiian i found
her on
facebook one time and
i never found her again they took
themselves off
i don't think they want to meet me i
have a daughter and two sons
the last one was a rape baby he was born
cross-sided
and had a rare disease because
the man that mary i married that was
killed his other wife in the fire his
other wife
before that committed suicide so i was
on a mission
to find out what he did to this lady
the whole house burned up except for
where her
carry a 15 000 cherry red
wood bedroom suit was you know and i
thought well [ __ ] it's
better being with one trick than being
with 50 each day
and you know he was an old man he was
impotent but he was just like
kissing my grandpa and i just
i just couldn't say and he was a
millionaire
and i would have had everything i just
made me sick
anyway you couldn't i went to the cops
i went to the cops because i found your
bible and i i happen to open bibles and
look at him from time to time
i opened up the bible and in the bible
had her diary the lady that burned up in
the fire
and it was saying how he was taken
around public drunk
on purpose so pissing [ __ ] you know on
herself
she was an alcoholic and she drank vodka
now in the newspaper clipping that i
found in the bible
it said that chin was found
and it and that's what caused the fire
the lighter exploded
the gin uh is flammable
vodka is not so i confront him
first first i go to the cops and i tell
them do you know that he
knew the cops and the cops went and told
him that i told them
uh dad that he killed his other wife
because he admitted to me yes i did to
put it out of her misery
she didn't she thought of a smoke
ventilation
but he made it seem like he crawled in
there and saved her so back to your
your life you left home at 13. yeah and
i i've been to texas
i've been man i've been if anybody said
you want to get high yeah
boom is that how drugs and prostitution
kind of came into your life yeah
yeah i always wanted to be you know
a singer i have songs i wanted to be a
dancer i
dance i wanted to be anything but what i
am you know i'm
down here i'm nothing i'm a [ __ ] i'm a
[ __ ] um um
i've been down here off and on since 89
but 91 for sure
and i have
never met the most meanest the most
nicest
the most cruelest the most deadliest the
most
courageous the most weakest
the most poorest the most richest people
in my life
down here i am
i don't know who to trust i don't know
the lie is so
much like the truth it's
people just promised me to get my kids
back they promised me this i marry
him uh [ __ ] me if you [ __ ] me i'll help
you do this
do that do that okay okay okay you know
but i'm tired of being no i don't want
to sell my body that's not what i like
that's not what i want that's not what i
wanted when i was a little girl
i just my family uh disowned me because
i had a black boyfriend and because of
that
my father never talked to me again he
died at 58. i was in prison in 1999.
everybody where do you stay now i
finally got housing out to 30 years
and right there at the abbey i've been
i've been raped twice in my building
i've had rob
my my tv my bike
so before that you were living in a tent
yeah okay
well no actually i just walked because i
didn't like being in the tent
every time i went to tent and i passed
out i took segments
so every time i passed out i passed out
and that's why i always wear i got two
pair of shorts on
right now and a pair of underwear and
the skirt
okay and i have to keep it that way and
kids are passed out somewhere
because by trying to get to the third
layer
[ __ ] then hopefully i'm awake
you know um i've been stabbed on sandule
in the stomach
for no reason um i've been beat
profusely for no reason uh
i'm not saying i haven't did anything
wrong like i said i got my parents
i shouldn't be saying this it shouldn't
be saying
um my brothers and sisters hate me
i don't know how to find my children to
tell them
uh right now i have hepatitis c virus
i'm taking the cure i just started
yesterday
i have arthritis in my neck i never went
to the doctor all
my life all my teeth are gone i always
had perfect teeth
how you lose your teeth getting knocked
out
uh you know just getting knocked out
getting knocked out
and uh
i um i feel ugly you know
i don't i don't feel worthy of
of anything like i want to write a book
about my life i want to write a book
about all this
you know what i mean i don't even know
where to start nobody even is interested
when i talk to anybody about it no one's
interested in wanting to write a book
and help me you know someone needs to
know a lot of [ __ ] i mean there's so
many things i jumped on the second
story second and third story windows
i've drummed out of moving cars
my baby was shot up with something in in
my belly button hurt that's why my baby
was cross-sided because
the head of gynecology didn't like me
and he was a partner
of my of my friend knew that i went to
the cops and said
i caught about the murder i'm not a rat
i've never
called the cops on anybody but then when
i read that lady's
thing and that and she was so sweet and
she was in the navy and she built ships
and she was a nice lady and then he
burned her up in the fire
i had to go to god's house
and they went and told him and he came
to me and said oh don't worry
and next thing you know he took me out
to eat he moved to china
this this older gentleman that i married
and louis massey
and he moved to china where there's no
extradition fees for
for uh costassis
right so what what is your drug today um
i smoke a pot uh i smoke
crack not as much i used to
i'll do crystal when i'm tired
uh i don't like serum i hate heroin
i hate anything to do with pills i just
don't i don't even want to be on drugs
if i was happy
and i had a light i wouldn't need
aerobics i
i wouldn't need drugs i'm not even they
don't even get
you know what i don't even draw myself i
don't even enjoy myself
i'm paranoid i'm scared
you know and what's the use in doing it
it's a waste of money and when i do get
money i need food
in my house i was a loan shark my whole
entire corona money checked
because i didn't want to go out there
hoeing so i've been borrowed money from
my addiction
i've been borrowed money for food and
hygiene
and i have to pay double i own fourteen
hundred dollars all of my money
and they sold to my other six hundred
what do you think about your life your
childhood kind of set you on this path
um my parents were alcoholics
uh my mother's side they were all doping
bikers i grew up in the bikers outlaws
chapter 11 bars
you know uh after the molestation yeah
young girl you left home yes he used to
come to my room and
when because me and my brother said to
all have to sleep in the same bed
and i knew that when the lights went out
and he was giving me he was going to
come in the room and get me and tell me
to go in the bathroom
and every night i would be scared you
know just
and i never told because he said he
killed me he killed my family
if i would have known my parents were
going to get killed and my brother
wouldn't know where i was at
he said sis if i didn't know where
you're at i would have told them
they went to the prison and said if you
don't tell us where you're from your
sister's out we're going to kill your
parents
they say he said i swear to god i don't
know and they didn't i went to maine
they had no idea
i said if they had known i would i would
have
told me i would have came and gave
myself to them
you know what i mean do you feel
responsible for that
yes and i've been hating myself
punishing myself ever since
i gave one of my children for adopting
three two
uh for adopting at birth in the same
family thank god
and utah and then my son alex haven't
seen since they took him out of my arms
said
anna and he was five he's 31.
well georgina what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your life
um not to trust everybody
not to be so gullible and
stop and listen i
always kept going wouldn't listen nobody
i knew everything
to listen to stop
and listen pay attention i'd be moving
so fast
i wasn't paying attention it doesn't
want to follow me 20 minutes
it's gonna rape me when i get around the
corner i just was moving
you know because i figured a moon target
can need to be hit
so i would keep moving because i was
scared when i stopped
somebody would always be there i would
walk mild
just to do a hit and peace i walked
all the way down to 16th street
underneath that bridge and thought i was
alone
got down did the hit he stood up and
four guys came out
out of nowhere and they previously raped
me for hours
i thought i was you know
i have a dude now i've been waiting on
about 12 years he's an ex-dope dealer
he got he said he's sick he's been gone
for four
[ __ ] months and he tells me he's in a
coma
i ask him to take a picture in the
hospital he can take picture in the
hospital
why can you take a picture of me and
then so now
why are you taking them back they said
because street rules are i've been
within 12 years the man's got pancreatic
cancer
daddy does have so i can't leave him
alone no matter what day he's done
to me left with a hoe and definitely for
four months
left me on thanksgiving left me on
christmas i had
christmas tree no christmas which is
that's
to me that's not what it's about anyway
but
i mean it's like i'm in a world of
people and i'm alone
i got no friends i got no family i've
ripped my family in florida they have
not written me back
i called them took a phone was
disconnected after 40 years
on facebook none of my friends on
facebook
they're all gone i
paid for my daughter i pictured anybody
i'm just stuck here i'm just here
i don't even feel like i live i just
exist
you know what i mean you know
i work i'm a hard worker anybody gives
me a job i'll work i'll clean
toilets i'll do anything but nobody
wants to give me a [ __ ] chance
i'm [ __ ] tired though
when's it gonna end no when somebody get
i need somebody to give me a chance
one chance and i promise you i wouldn't
let you down
i still have a heart after all that
i have prayed and no not god with god
do not let my heart be hard like all
these people
all the time and so i can't walk over
somebody
and they say oh he's drunk leave him
alone no i got to see his breathing
i got to see his false in there if i
walk over the car and he's dead
when i go here god bless now [ __ ] i
don't know i'm in hell now
you know and then i prayed for an
apartment how grateful can i be
god gave me an apartment and i can't
stand it i've gotten eaten up by bed
bugs and bugs and [ __ ] spiders and
[ __ ] i lived outside for 30 years
and didn't have all this [ __ ] on me like
bringing
in off the street and i wanted to get
bringing in and giving the homeless
shelters they're [ __ ] bringing in all
the bed bugs and all the [ __ ] bugs
and [ __ ] stuff
all right i'm sorry for crying it's okay
it's okay thank you for sharing your
story
yeah that's nothing
that's nothing yeah yeah man that's
nothing
all right i just tried to break it down
for you you did a good job with that
thank you so much darling granny kyle
what did you call me john
darling dolly i called you darling okay
and that you student would call me nice
name